alors voilà
donc bon on est d'accord les filles vous
êtes tout formidable c'est juste les
césars donc le césar de la meilleure
actrice dans un second rôle est attribué
à la troisième est étranger à ce prix
tentons après l'italienne diana l'isi
pour la reine margot et en malaisie
disparue le 18 décembre et trois ans
après l'espagnol quand même nord pour
les femmes du 6e étage elle joue
assistant de la comédienne incarné par
juliette binoche dans ce film d'olivier
assayas était son premier choix
elle avait dû un temps renoncé au rôle
pour des raisons d'emploi du temps et
mia wasikowska aurait pris sa place mais
porte heureusement kristen stewart a
joué dans ce film on la retrouvera au
cinéma le 18 mars en fille de john moore
dans still alice
sur la tâche s'il vous plaît parce que
j'ai les mains moites
merci à la la je ne peux même pas
d'oublier mon petit papier
je suis de ceux-là
j'apporte pas français mais je promets
de travailler de joliette
merci merci beaucoup je suis ici devant
un parterre de personnalités et
évidemment tout le monde connaît
juliette athlan elle est formidable
c'est tellement difficile d'être ici
devant juliette qui fait vraiment tout
ce que je faisais était faire comme elle
et je t'aime j'adore juliette à les
charges présenté à un univers qui au
moins jeune actrice américaine est
absolument extraordinaire qui restent à
exploiter l'une des personnes préféré au
moins et olivier à chaque fois que je me
demandais ce que tu lances et sans
beaucoup de mots je me suis rendu compte
finalement que je prenais ce chemin si
bien tracée pour moi merci beaucoup
merci à vous tous et et je suis vraiment
ravi d'être ici ce soir merci
m